I was just overhearing a little bit I
heard you use the word culture shift and
I've heard other people use that when
they're talking about you and kind of
what you've been doing in this business
what does getting the Sherry Lansing
Leadership Award mean to you I mean it
is beyond the biggest honor I was really
humbled when when Meredith called me and
said that they want to give you this
award I didn't even know what to say I I
you know just to be part of the legacy
of this woman who broke through so many
barriers ran a studio produced so many
amazing movies and did so much for our
industry in so many ways is really just
so humbling you know and to be here I've
watched everybody sweet sean does speech
I've watched Tina Fey's be just
everybody and and it's really it's
nerve-racking and scary to be up in
front of that huge group of people but I
mean nervously honors is it more
soothing to have your family in the
crowd watching or is okay good okay I
was like you guys you got a shot for me
cuz I'm really nervous and I look out
there and it makes me feel grounded
they're my ready you guys all together
means a lot to me that they're there
either they just always support me and I
it's really I'm really lucky to have a
great family I don't think I could do
what I do if I didn't have that support
that I have at home you also have a
great tribe of women you know in this
business that really ride for you and
support for you and then at the Golden
Globe nominations we see all you guys
nominated together you'd and Jennifer
together and Nicole all in the same
category yeah I mean it was just an
incredible day to get that call and to
see the acknowledgement of Jen and
Nicole and Meryl and laura dern and it
just goes on and on but it's it's really
humbling to be part of these huge
incredibly impressive groups of people
and I'm just happy to be part of the
team we stalk your Instagram a little
bit so you posted I just want laura dern
to be proud of me just change their bio
- I just want Laura Dern to be proud of
me and I think it's a mood I think it's
like I think it's the new goals for 2020
and finally can you say wreath
Witherspoon five times
you know and it's so funny because my
name is hard to say anyway but if you
would say any version of it it gets
really confusing every talk show I'm on
there like re reese witherspoon
I get it I feel it I know
[Music]